souvent sur le le terrain en Ukraine on
va parler dans un instant de des
conséquences de des événements de ce
week-end avec vous mais d'abord revenons
sur ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui en
Russie donc pris goji on vient de
l'évoquer avec Julien Colling est
toujours viser par une enquête pénale
Poutine avait dit le contraire il avait
abandonné les poursuites pour vous les
les jours de prégoji sont comptés
avec votre collègue je pense que
aujourd'hui après toute cette
histoire-là a clairement rigolé n'a été
affaiblie il a perdu en crédibilité
Wagner a perdu en crédibilité également
et si aujourd'hui il se trouve au
Belarus et non plus en Russie c'est
parce que très clairement ces jours sont
comptés et il ne doit plus vraiment être
en sécurité je pense que ce qui s'est
passé c'est que Poutine lui-même ne le
pensait pas que privilégie n'était prêt
à aller aussi loin que cela et cela ne
sera jamais pardonné que ce soit par le
ministère de la Défense russe actuelle
ou bien par des personnes telles que le
président Mel de la Russie pour vous
c'est pris goji qui a été affaibli
fragilisé plus que Poutine je pense que
les deux ont perdu en crédibilité et les
deux ont perdu en termes de puissance et
en termes d'autorité mais celui qui est
réellement on va dire à concerner
aujourd'hui par cette question de jours
comptés c'est très clairement pris
d'origine pour l'instant Poutine peut se
maintenir au pouvoir je ne pense pas
qu'il ait été affaibli au point de
quitter le Kremlin par contre rigogyne
je pense vraiment que ces jours sont
comptés mais les deux ont été affaiblis
il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus sur le
sort de la milice vous en pensez quoi
est-ce que elle va continuer
à agir est-ce qu'elle va continuer à
être une armée parallèle est-ce qu'elle
va continuer aussi à participer à
l'effort de guerre en Ukraine pour
l'instant c'est pas clair pour l'instant
ce qu'on sait c'est que il y a des
rumeurs qui disent que par exemple le
groupe Wagner pourrait partir en Afrique
c'était apparemment l'une des demandes
de prix d'origine lors de sa
conversation et lors des négociations
avec le président Belarus le cacher le
corps on n'a pas encore de confirmation
à ce niveau là mais je pense que pour
l'instant ils vont participer d'une
manière ou d'une autre avec une
intensité différente et bien moins
importante qu'il y a encore quelques
mois par exemple dans la région de
Donetsk qui met néanmoins ils vont
participer je pense encore dans des
opérations en Ukraine je ne crois pas en
la thèse d'une invasion vers la région
de kif parce que là on essaie
d'expliquer que c'est un coup un coup de
maître j'ai vu sur Twitter certains
utilisateurs dire que le président
Poutine jouait aux échecs en 5
dimensions et que maintenant Wagner est
à 100 km de kiffe moi je n'y crois pas
du tout on sait que la ligne de défense
au niveau de du nord du pays et
extrêmement forte les Ukrainiens ont
réellement fortifié position là donc je
ne pense pas qu'une d'invasion est
possible de ce côté là en tout cas pas
tout de suite et je ne pense pas que
cela soit quelque chose que Wagner
puisse mener en tout cas les
conséquences sur le front en Ukraine
elles sont encore difficiles à évaluer
il y a est-ce qu'il y a un risque que
Poutine se venge sur l'Ukraine
non parce que enfin comment dire
qu'est-ce que cela signifierait
c'est-à-dire ce comment est-ce qu'on
peut encore se venger la Russie frappe
régulièrement le territoire ukrainien on
a décidé nucléaire comme le dit Vladimir
Zelenski par exemple
oui mais sauf que ça c'est pas forcément
en rapport avec brigogine si vous parlez
de la situation en général sur le
terrain alors oui la Russie est dans une
situation assez désespérée on a vu ce
qui s'est passé le 6 juin de cette année
avec le barrage de karlovecka on
comprend très clairement que c'est la
Russie qui est derrière la Russie la
l'Ukraine n'a rien à gagner dans cette
histoire et elle a perdu certains de ses
citoyens après cet attaque maintenant on
parle effectivement de cette centrale et
on en parle beaucoup parce que on
connaît pas au sérieux les risques de
l'explosion du barrage au final on a vu
que 7 mois après les premières
provocations l'explosion a eu lieu
maintenant on parle de plus en plus de
cette centrale et je peux vous dire que
si par exemple auparavant même en
Ukraine l'histoire de ce barrage n'était
pas populaire ou bien n'était quasiment
pas évoqué au sein de la population la
centrale nucléaire on en parle vraiment
tous les jours et bien que les
Ukrainiens ne pensent pas que la Russie
puisse utiliser une arme tactique ou
stratégique contre l'Ukraine parce que
cela serait trop gros
l'hypothèse d'un potentiel accident
provoqué par la Russie sur la centrale
et tout à fait et quelque chose que l'on
entend souvent au sein de la population
ukrainienne c'est quelque chose que
j'entends dans mon entourage absolument
tous les jours lors des changes avec des
locaux avec des collègues avec
absolument tout le monde
vous voyez comment la suite
sur ce que pourrait faire Poutine
notamment en interne est-ce qu'il y a un
risque de de répression encore plus
élevée des opposants à Poutine on entre
là dans une chasse aux traîtres
je pense que peut-être qu'avec cette
histoire de pseudo coup d'État tentative
de coup d'état ce qui peut se passer
c'est que Poutine peut effectivement
décider de purger une partie des
traîtres une partie des personnes qui
ont décidé de prendre
le
qui ont décidé de rejoindre on va dire
le camp de prix gaugine sur ces sur ces
24 heures en question mais je ne suis
pas sûr que cela est un effet absolument
massif ou que cela ait des conséquences
importantes sur le terrain ce qui est
possible par contre c'est que ce goût
effectivement quitte le ministère de la
Défense et que cela soit un autre proche
de Poutine qui prennent la place on
parle de Dieu mais un ancien garde du
corps du président Poutine les
Ukrainiens disent que pour peut-être ça
pourrait être une mauvaise chose pour
eux parce que ils savent que ce Hugo est
incompétent c'était la raison principale
à de on va dire de ce mouvement de
contestation de révolte de prix gaugine
et de Wagner donc peut-être en mettant
une autre personne à savoir dumin et
bien peut-être que la situation changera
non pas en la faveur de l'Ukraine mais
justement
peut-être qu'il y aura un nouveau plan
stratégique qui mettra à mal en tout cas
en partie les opérations qui sont menées
en ce moment en Ukraine mais le moral
des Ukrainiens est élevé ils savent que
la contre-offensive alliance en ce
moment que des opérations stratégiques
ont déjà eu lieu et qu'elle continue
aujourd'hui le village de rive nopil a
été libéré dans la région de Donetsk et
ce n'est que le début et les Ukrainiens
sont conscients merci beaucoup pour
votre commentaire sur France 24 Cyril
amour ski journaliste de guerre
franco-russe